bonsoir de la même façon qu'il n'y a pas
eu de 19 en première partie cette
édition de ce soir sera écourtée un
journal préparé et réalisé par les
personnels non grévistes et au cours
duquel il sera presque exclusivement
question de cette journée de grève
nationale dans la fonction publique une
greffe qui pour commencer à paralyser en
grande partie la ville de paris stéphane
du bain éric pelletier
ils ne sont que quelques irréductibles à
attendre un hypothétique bus vélo
enchaîné métro fermés j'habite place
d'italie et je viens levallois imaginez
un peu traversée de paris à monza 60
bollée j'ai des collègues qui n'ont pas
pu venir parce qu'ils habitent en
banlieue et tout ça c'était trois heures
d'embouteillages aujourd'hui c'est
l'horreur pare chocs contre pare choc ce
soir et gare saint-lazare déserte ce
matin
[Musique]
demain
un trafic sncf et ratp quasiment nul
quelques promeneurs et des commerçants
désabusé depuis ce matin 7 heures je pas
24 clients c'est tout autre chose voyez
ce qu'on fait ménage il y avait personne
à la gare c'était vraiment triste j'ai
jamais vu la gare comme ça
métro désert aussi seulement six rames
circulent sur deux lignes seulement moi
je n'ai pas le choix je travaille je
fais partie de ces quelques pour cent de
la population qui font vivre plus de
l'autre moitié
alors moi l'aval de la greffe pour moi
ça n'existe pas et pendant à perdre
comme ça on est bien rentré chez soi à
revoir sa petite famille toutes les
paires dont les a qu'une fois tous les
quinze jours des fois moins 10% de but
ultime recours le stop mais ferment
parce que j'ai un rendez vous et je suis
pressé jeunes qu'ils encourent à pied et
c'est assez dur parce que j'en prenne
pas trop en stop et ils ont un peu peur
une raison de plus votre avis vélo n'est
pas polluant et ce n'est pas en raison
des grèves
les grévistes de la sncf avait décidé de
poursuivre aujourd'hui leur mouvement de
grève après avoir défendu hier leur
système de retraite il voulait faire
pression et cela durera sans doute
jusqu'à lundi sur le nouveau contrat de
plan qui va lier la sncf à l'état
l'entreprise étant très dangereusement
endettée jean yves perrin bernie mairie
pour la continuité de la grève de 24
heures
l'assemblée générale des contrôleurs
d'austerlitz est unanime
la grève est reconduite jusqu'à lundi
matin et si le mouvement est bien suivi
c'est que les cheminots s'inquiètent à
la fois de la réforme de la sécu qui
menace le régime de retraite et du futur
contrat de plan qui supprimerait des
kilomètres de lignes et des emplois
c'est uniquement de la rentabilité de la
rentabilité et on refuse d'admettre que
la sncf c'est avant tout un service
public et qu'il joue un grand rôle dans
l'aménagement du territoire conséquence
de cette grève un trafic quasi nul sur
le réseau banlieue à montparnasse il ne
valait mieux pas raté son départ
côté grandes lignes un seul train ce
soir par destination mais peu
d'affluence
on est samedi la plupart des piégés sont
des voyageurs débarquant tout juste de
l'avion
quand je suis parti c'était juste le
changement de gouvernement donc je pense
que les choses sont pas améliorées
depuis fait longtemps que vous attendez
hier soir on n'arrivait pas à orly pas
de métro pas de bus taxis
surprise battra les gares parisiennes ne
sont pas les seuls à connaître ces
perturbations à toulouse pas de train
régional seulement deux trains pour
paris et 1 pour bordeaux la grève est
reconduite jusqu'à demain à strasbourg
la direction qui prévoyait d'abord c'est
ce train sur les 120 circulant
normalement n'est pas sûr de tous les
maintenir les cheminots poursuivre leur
grève jusqu'à lundi à lyon pas de train
régional non plus six tgv vers paris et
5 venant de la capitale
une situation qui doit se prolonger
demain toute la journée comme à rennes à
lille à bordeaux ou à marseille
bref c'est l'ensemble du réseau ferré
français qui tourne au ralenti
la senza fait donc lourdement endetté je
vous le disais est ce nouveau contrat
entre l'entreprise et d'état qui doit
être connus lundi fait peur aux
cheminots y voient une remise en cause
de leurs conditions de travail
davantage acquis également et de la
nature même du service public des
chemins de fer français pascal golomer
luc blache open un chiffre un seul pour
résumer l'urgence des décisions à
prendre
la sncf a accumulé jusqu'à aujourd'hui
175 milliards de francs de dette en
remboursant uniquement les intérêts de
cette dette
l affiche du coup un déficit de 12
milliards de francs cette année qui
viennent s'ajouter à la dette évidemment
un cercle vicieux qui veut casser
c'est tout l'objet des négociations
entre l'état et la sncf
ce contrat va être un contrat d'
d'efforts partagés comme on dit c'est à
dire que l'entreprise va s'engager à des
améliorations des progrès l'amélioration
de sa qualité vu poil par les clients et
aussi du côté de l'état l'état va nous
encourager nous aider à cette évolution
y compris financièrement sur 1 62 point
l'état qui fera d'abord un chèque tout
de suite pour alléger la dette 25 à 30
milliards de francs dit on mais rien
n'est encore officiel pour le reste tout
dépendra de l'amélioration des résultats
et donc des efforts que fera la sncf
au programme la poursuite des
suppressions d'emplois cinq mille par an
actuellement
le chiffre pourrait s'accroître une
moindre augmentation des salaires aussi
enfin une nouvelle organisation du
travail une plus grande polyvalence des
agents
à cela s'ajoute le transfert vers les
régions de la gestion des petites ling
ling souvent déficitaires beaucoup
pourraient être transférés sur autocar
ou fermer définitivement
autant de sujets d'inquiétude pour les
cheminots c'est une partie des faits
ce qui se joue la direction et le
gouvernement le savent eux qui redoute
plus que tout un long conflit social
comme celui de 1986 et cheminots avaient
alors fait grève pendant 22 jours
les autres titres de l'actualité le
mouvement de grève à la sncf s'est
poursuivie aujourd'hui dans toute la
france et la table ronde entre les
syndicats et le président de la sncf qui
présentait son contrat de plan avec
l'état n'a rien donné jean yves perrin
jean luc est qu un président très
attendu par les organisations syndicales
devant l'ampleur de la grève tous
direction comme syndicats voulaient se
rencontrer le plus vite possible
au menu de cette table ronde la
présentation de l'avant projet du
contrat de plan mais si les efforts de
productivité à faire par les cheminots
sont listés il manque un chapitre
essentiel
l'argent que va donner l'état en
contrepartie des efforts demandés et ce
chiffre ne sera connue que mardi
prochain
une table ronde qui a pas servi à grand
chose puisqu'il s'avère que le président
bergougnoux est hors jeu dans le la
protection sociale sur la protection
sociale semble aussi hors jeu sur le
contrat de vente ce qui n'a pas été
capable de nous fournir la moindre
indication sur la position de l'état par
rapport à l'avenir de l'entreprise aux
deux questions posées quant à l'avenir
du régime de retraite et de prévoyance
des cheminots il n'y a pas d'assurance
et quant au contrat de plan on nous dit
on signera comme prévu dans les délais
prévus
c'est justement ce qu'on ne veulent pas
les cheminots au contraire on a plutôt
l'impression que cette réunion ne peut
faire qu'ajouter au mécontentement
ambiant
résultat tous les syndicats de cheminots
appellent ce soit va la poursuite du
mouvement
une grève déjà très suivies ce week end
à paris comme en province à la gare
saint lazare par exemple
trois trains seulement ce soir pour la
normandie le réseau banlieue tourne lui
aussi au ralenti
un train toutes les heures en moyenne
pour chaque destination
en fait tout le réseau ferré français
est touché dans ces proportions
demain la situation sera semblable il
faudra savoir prendre son mal en
patience
monsieur bergougnoux bonsoir reste que
le président la sncf considère ce soir
que ces négociations sont un échec comme
le considèrent les syndicats bah si vous
entendez par là que la rencontre de ce
soir n'a pas arrêté la grève
oui bien sûr il faut bien comprendre
l'origine de la crise que nous
traversons il apparaît très clairement à
travers les déclarations que nous avons
entendu il s'agit d'un amalgame entre
les inquiétudes des cheminots sur
l'avenir nos régimes de retraite et que
leur inquiétude sur l'avenir de
l'entreprise qui s'incarne 1 verge au
contrat de plan
sur le premier point je n'ai plus que
rappeler les déclarations clarifie
catrice pour fait différemment du
gouvernement hier sur le second point le
contrat de plan nous avançons vous
avancez mais les syndicats appellent à
une poursuite de la grève
qu'est-ce qui pourrait débloquer la
situation à votre avis je crois que la
question du contrat de plan on reste
malgré tout
essentiel et j'ai pu ce soir remettre
aux organisations syndicales un avant
projet qui traite déjà deux questions
importantes
la pérennité de l'entreprise de son
statut le service public
et puis aussi tordre le cou au passage
cette affaire des 6000 kilomètres de
lignes que l'on va supprimer et qui
n'est qu'imaginaire mais surtout j'ai pu
dire vrai je confirmerai dans deux jours
lorsque le mécanisme de désendettement
par lequel l'état accompagnera nos
efforts sera précisée j'ai aujourd'hui
la conviction que ce contrat temps pour
l'entreprise est une vraie chance à
saisir
grâce à l'aide de l'état si nous prenons
notre destin en main nous pouvons
redresser durablement l'entreprise
monsieur bergougnoux je vous remercie
madame nota merci d'avoir répondu à
notre invitation ce soir le président de
la république n'est pas en odeur de
sainteté auprès de monsieur blondel vous
non plus que pensez vous de l'attitude
actuelle le monsieur blondel dans cette
crise
je n'ai pas en juger mais en
l'occurrence pour ce qui est de la
rencontre avec le président république
que j'ai eu aussi la différence entre
marc blondel et moi et peut-être que je
n'attendais pas de confidence jacques
chirac jacques chirac m'a demandé quels
étaient mes positions les pulsions de la
ciel d'été sur la réforme de la sécurité
sociale je lui aussi beaucoup disent que
je ne souhaitais pas voir dans cette
réforme et il m'a dit clairement à la
sortie madame je vous ai bien écouté
mais vous savez bien que les arbitrages
appartiennent au gouvernement
bien sûr et je dis monsieur est un marc
bourdages lorsqu'il s'en prend à vous
accuse finalement d'être d'accord avec
le gouvernement sur la réforme de la
sécurité sociale
en schématisant peut évidemment le prix
le gouvernement sur l'assurance maladie
chantons bien repris des positions et
des revendications que nous avons à la
cfdt depuis plusieurs mois et plusieurs
années alors évidemment je ne vais pas
au syndicalisme que vous prenez par
rapport à la cgt à l'évidence la sphère
de la sécurité sociale le démontre mais
ça fait déjà longtemps que nous avons le
sentiment qu'il faut aujourd'hui un
syndicalisme qui soient de plus en plus
utile et efficace un syndicalisme qui
fonctionne différemment quand on a 5
millions d'exclus 3 millions
cinq cent mille chômeurs donc c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui nous avons envie d'être
un syndicat un contre-pouvoir libre
autonome mais efficace et obtenant des
résultats on vient d'entendre
monsieur bergougnoux le président sncf
on a vu que la situation était bloquée à
la sncf on a une semaine qui s'annonce
avec de nouvelles manifestations comment
voyez vous les choses s'opérer ont
écouté à la sncf je dirais que c'est là
une démonstration de plusieurs années de
manque de courage tente de l'état que
des présidents ont certains présidents
de la sncf aussi c'est à dire qu'ils ont
toujours repousser plus loin des
décisions qui devaient être prises
on est au pied du mur donc plus c'est
douloureux mais plus a réagi parce que
vous êtes d'accord
je pense qu'aujourd'hui ça c'est une
mode
tout dépend au service de quoi il à fond
je crois qu'aujourd'hui les cheminots
sont en droit de demander au
gouvernement qu'est ce que vous voulez
pour la sncf demain votre contrat de
plan vous voulez faire bouger la sncf
peut-être mais pour en faire quoi donc
comprendre qu'il faut bouger
ensuite ils sont en droit de leur
demander qu'est ce qu'ils vont faire
pour assurer les complémentarités
nécessaire entre le rail et la route par
exemple et ils sont évidemment en droit
de leur demander à quelle sauce les
salariés vont être aussi concernant ses
causes sociales vous pensez que s'est
terminée la réforme va passer de
gouvernement peut tenir sur cette
position
un million c'est le mans je pense
qu'elle peut jeudi qu'elle doit passer
concernant l'assurance maladie et nous
ne serons pas du côté est de la cfdt de
ceux qui veulent la faire échouer mais
nous avons gouvernement à l'oeil
la vigilance s'impose car maintenant il
faut appliquer les orientations et ses
lacs le gouvernement va être au pied
d'un mur contre tous les lobbys dernière
chose nicole notât
vous avez été quelque peu chahuté par
vos propres par certains de vos propres
militants nordistes un mauvais souvenir
ça vous a choqué vous en êtes remise ça
m'a choqué moralement plus que
physiquement car j'étais bien protégé
mais c'est vrai que c'est tout à fait
déplaisant de voir que cela peut arriver
dans le mouvement syndical
ces gens étaient très minoritaires
agressif verbalement et physiquement ça
n'honore pas ceux qu'ils entendent
défendre
enfin je veux dire que les mais j'en
profite merci de me donner votre antenne
car je ne pourrais pas répondre
personnellement à tous les messages de
sympathie et de soutien n'ont été dont
j'ai été l'objet ce week-end et il me
vont droit au coeur je vais vous dire
pas seulement parce que ils ont eu le
sentiment que j'avais
a passé un mauvais moment mais parce que
beaucoup se terminer sous le par cette
forme et ses encouragements
nicole tient bon sur la sécu tu tiens le
bon bout et on est avec toi merci nicole
notât petite rectification nous apporte
pas vont pas donner l'antenne vous avons
invités je dis ça pour les censeurs qui
nous regarde de très près merci de cette
erreur de langage
en ce qui concerne le conflit proprement
dit une nouvelle négociation cet après
midi avec le ministre des affaires
sociales monsieur barreau n'a pas abouti
les cheminots ont tout de même obtenu de
conserver leur régime spécial de
retraite demain force ouvrière la cgt
appelle à une nouvelle journée de grèves
contre la réforme de la sécurité sociale
le trafic ferroviaire risque d'être pour
la cinquième journée consécutive
très fortement perturbé pascal golomer
lambert 30 donc
la grève a été reconduite séance
d'information cet après midi au fond
d'un hangar une petite poignée de
grévistes
les sédentaires comme on les appelle ils
travaillent en principe au guichet de la
gare de l'est et ils sont désormais tout
aussi déterminé que leurs collègues
roulant à poursuivre le mouvement
quand le président bergougnoux convoque
les organisations syndicales
on pouvait penser peut-être qu'il avait
d'autres propositions à faire sur le
contrat de plan et il n'en est rien donc
aujourd'hui nous n'avons aucune raison
et les cheminots d'ailleurs le montre
massivement encore aujourd'hui pour
arrêter le mouvement
aucune avancée aujourd'hui du côté de la
direction de la sncf surprise en
revanche en début d'après midi
jacques barrot invite tous les syndicats
à son ministère pour évoquer évidemment
le fameux régime des retraites
départ à 55 ans et durée de cotisation
moindre que dans le privé un régime que
le gouvernement veut réformer mais
auquel s'accrochent les cheminots ce
soir le ministre l'a promis
rien n'est décidé objecté consolidation
à moyen et long terme de nos régimes
spéciaux de retraite méthode
une commission composée de personnalités
indépendantes et compétentes assurances
il y aura une concertation approfondie
pour les syndicats pas de quoi être
rassuré concernant le statut notamment
le régime de retraite le gouvernement
n'a pas l'intention manifestement de
donner des signes d'apaisement aux
cheminots rien 9 confirmation d'une
mobilisation nécessaire pour continuer
d'essayer de faire reculer le
gouvernement sur cet aspect particulier
comme sur la question du contrat de plan
et ils se retrouveront tous demain sous
une seule banderole dans la
manifestation contre le plan ses clips
du gouvernement le gouvernement a donc
annoncé aujourd'hui qu'il augmentait de
12 milliards 37 milliards au total son
aide au remboursement de la dette de la
sncf contre un effort de productivité
donnant-donnant chantage ont répondu les
syndicats le gouvernement a ajouté qu'il
n'entendait pas remettre en cause de
régimes de retraite spécifique des
cheminots et ce soir la négociation a
repris pascal golomer jacques berniche
attention une table ronde peut en cacher
une autre n'a pas être allé hier chez
chaque barreau les syndicats de
cheminots on retrouve ce soir leur
président jean bergougnoux cette fois
pour parler en détails du contrat de
plan
on le sait depuis ce matin l'état
reprendra l'année prochaine 37 des 175
milliards de francs de dette de la sncf
sans contrepartie pour le reste tout
dépendra des résultats de l'entreprise
et donc des efforts des cheminots en
matière salariale notamment si le
résultat s'améliore la dette sera
allégée ce sera francs pour francs
donnant-donnant chantage dénoncent les
syndicats le donnant donnant et fossés
d'entrer dans la mesure où c'est la
dette de l'état que la sncf supporte
c'est pas la dette des cheminots n'est
ni des usagers c'est l'actionnaire
unique et étape qui n'a pas participé à
ces investissements dans le mode
ferroviaire c'est donc à lui de trouver
les moyens pour assumer ses
responsabilités m'avoir preco ce plan
que rejette la cgt la cfdt c'est pour
jean bergougnoux le plan de la dernière
chance
encore faut-il convaincre des cheminots
lancer dans le conflit le plus dur
depuis 1986
les syndicats cgt cfdt fo et autonome de
la ratp annonce une reconduction de leur
mouvement de grève pour demain attention
donc pour les parisiens et les habitants
l'île de france mais c'est à la sncf que
l'on s'attend à une nouvelle journée
encore pratiquement 100 trains les
cheminots conteste à la fois la mise en
cause de leur régime de retraite et le
contrat de plan que leur entreprise doit
passer avec l'état pour réduire son
endettement considérable et malgré
toutes les avances faites aujourd'hui du
côté du gouvernement une majorité de
cheminots sont sur une ligne du
reportage dans un important centre de la
sncf
c'est au mans jacques cardoze nathalie
gallet depuis hier 13 heures plus aucun
train ne circule
et pour cause il occupe un point
stratégique le poste de régulation à
commande informatisée 200 cheminots sont
réunis ici autour des mêmes
revendications
le régime des retraites mais aussi
l'incertitude de l'emploi via le contrat
de plan sncf qui prévoit la suppression
de 6000 kilomètres de lignes régionales
riche pour l'emploi nouveau la sncf
jusque là tenus il ya 500 emplois -
aucune assurance sur l'avenir de charge
de travail de trois ans à venir
aussi l'action d'aujourd'hui est
clairement aussi vers l'est
âgées l'accès à des gens que j'ai fait
ce public chose d'important il a même
territoire
quand l annonce faite aujourd'hui par le
gouvernement concernant l'effacement
d'une partie de la dette
elle ne satisfait pas ces grévistes
l'état s'est pourtant engagé à reprendre
en deux tranches 37 milliards de francs
sur 175 milliards de la dette globale
par la suite toute amélioration du
résultat d'exploitation sera accompagnée
d'un allègement par l'état sur les
charges financières de la sncf 7
milliards pour l'année 96 et après on va
demander aux cheminots de faire
l'économie sur les emplois sur les
salaires d'un milliard pour toucher 1
milliard ans répartis du gouvernement
vous trouvez que c'est un accord normal
nous on est là sncf
on n'est pas des temps nos droits nos
valeurs on est un service public on
tient à rester service public ce soir
des groupes de manifestants ont défilé
dans les rues du mans pour certains
syndicalistes
il ne s'agit pas d'un coup de colère
passager mais bien d'une action
prolongée
pas question de toucher au statut en
signe de colère
ils sont même allés jusqu'à mur et la
permanence du rpr de la salle
au septième jour de la grève de la sncf
d'autres services publics ont été
appelés à arrêter le travail c'est le
cas à edf gdf dont les agents
manifestaient ce matin à paris en dehors
du plan de réforme de la sécurité
sociale gaziers et électriciens sont
inquiets de l'arrivée prochaine de la
concurrence sur leurs marchés jean-paul
chapelle frédéric bazille le barrage des
crs aura été le plus fort
les militants cgt n'ont pas atteint leur
objectif rendre visite à l'assemblée
nationale
motif de la colère la menace qui pèse
selon les syndicats sur le service
public
le monopole d'edf gdf que dans le
collimateur de bruxelles qui réclame
l'ouverture des marchés de l'électricité
et du gaz
plus de concurrence pour faire baisser
les prix une perspective qui inquiète
les syndicats
la concurrence ne servira que les
intérêts des grandes entreprises et que
ceux qui auront à pâtir de cette réalité
là ce seront les usagers qui verront
notamment une augmentation du coût de
l'électricité d'une manière importante
comme on l'a connu en grande bretagne
ces dernières années mais les salariés
redoutent surtout une remise en cause de
leur statut
car pour faire face à la concurrence
européenne l'entreprise publique est-ce
que d'ouvrir son capital à d'autres
actionnaires
on touche actuellement au monopole de la
distribution
or quand on remet en cause le monopole
de la production leur monopole d'import
export aient le monopole de distribution
c'est la privatisation qui intervient
comme en grande bretagne dans leur
cortège les électriciens et gaziers ont
été rejoints aujourd'hui par des
cheminots et des postiers comme
jean les df gdf craignent pour leur
retraite dans le cadre du plan juppé
il risque aussi de perdre les avantages
de leur région spéciale à moitié des 130
centres de tri postaux en france sont
également grève contre la réforme de la
sécurité sociale et solidaire avec les
cheminots reportage à rouen d'abord et
dans d'autres centres pascal golomer
l'ugb aziz
ici on n'est pas en grève pour des
intérêts étroits et égoïste de
catégorielles on est en grève contre le
plan juppé
le centre de tri de sotteville lès rouen
bloqués depuis lundi soir depuis le vote
de la grève malgré trois assemblées
générales chaque jour est toujours le
même mot d'ordre qui revient dans les
conversations
non à la casse des acquis sociaux non à
la remise en cause des régimes de
retraite beaucoup de collègues disait
est ce qu'on va subir toutes les
attaques
à chaque fois en répondant juste 24
heures souhaité aller plus loin le fait
que les cheminots et montrer la voie
c'est le cas de le dire a décidé
l'action ce soir
50 des 130 centres de tri de la poste
sont occupés avec 50 à 90% de grévistes
une grève qui ne s'étant pour l'instant
qu'à une vingtaine de bureaux à paris
grenoble lyon ou valence ailleurs les
guichets reste ouvert les facteurs font
encore leur tournée mais la distribution
du courrier pourrait devenir de plus en
plus chaotique dans les jours qui
viennent faty le mouvement se poursuit
et c'est bien attention des principaux
syndicats qui appellent partout à la
grève reconductible
la saint-éloi saint patron des métallos
est en principe jours de fête chez les
cheminots dans les ateliers d'hellemmes
près de lille un atelier qui s'occupe de
la maintenance des tgv
l'ambiance était cette année plutôt à la
morosité en compagnie d'anne mourgues et
de jean-christophe rises portrait d'un
cheminot plutôt amer ils ont voulu
sauver les apparences mais il n'avait
pas envie de faire la fête
aujourd'hui la saint-éloi des pour ses
cheminots un goût plutôt amer
le barbecue leur servaient plus à
réchauffer les corps que les coeurs au
milieu du piquet de grève
rabastens se dit frustré il travaille à
la maintenance des tgv en fin de
carrière son salaire et de 9300 francs
par mois
ils redoutent la privatisation il craint
surtout de perdre 20% sur sa retraite
j'étais du pot volet ont renoncé d'eux
on me pompe on veut pas pendant des
années voilà il a fallu la postérité
on en retrait de plus en plus sur la
fiche de paye ou demain de m'attraper de
plus en plus un port je paye dans tous
les secteurs et on nous dit encore je
suis un anti un anti un mec qui se lève
tous les jours à 5 heures du matin qui
fait sa journée qui paie ses impôts
on y prennent les devants comme premier
de plus en beauté il y a trente ans il a
quitté le privé prêt à gagner moi il a
choisi la sncf pour son statut alors la
pilule est d'autant plus dure à avaler
j'estime qu'aujourd'hui ya 55 ans doit
partir en retraite décemment en a
quarante minutes qui me permet de
profiter de la vie de son atelier de
maintenance
il rêvait souvent à la retraite il
voulait parcourir la france faire du
vélo possible à 55 ans dit il plus à 60
c'est pour ça qu'il se bat même si
aujourd'hui la grève lui a déjà coûté
2000 francs aujourd'hui je perds de
l'argent ça ne remet en cause de nuage
peut-être mais je j'irai jusqu'au bout
je ne veux pas perdre notre village que
j'ai de dire je drômois comment ne pas
une vie décente
un autre descente demain il sera encore
au milieu du piquet de grève sans les
sandwichs ni les merguez
mais avec la même détermination semaine
décisive également pour le mouvement
universitaire françois bayrou recevra
demain dimanche les représentants de la
coordination étudiante qui s'est réunie
jusqu'à 4 heures du matin un censier
pour élaborer sa plateforme
revendicatrice et pour composer après
des manoeuvres de coulisses pas toujours
très claires la délégation qui soit
reçue au ministère
françoise david c'était hier soir à la
faculté de censier environ 300
représentants d'universités en grève
s'étaient retrouvés pour élaborer une
plate forme de revendications a présenté
au ministre de l'éducation nationale
les étudiants exigent en urgence deux
milliards de francs pour assurer les
travaux de réfection des bâtiments
anciens
également deux milliards de francs pour
le fonctionnement mais il pense aussi à
un avenir proche
nous lui demandons une map programmation
budgétaire quinquennal savoir que on lui
demande la création de 25 mille postes
d'enseignants chercheurs de 20000 postes
de personnels techniques et
administratifs
on lui demande si cette loi de
programmation la chiffre à 50 milliards
de francs les étudiants qui tenait en
fin d'après midi une nouvelle réunion
réclame également la réquisition des
universités privées
il appelle à la grève générale dans les
universités et à des manifestations
mardi prochain
la délégation qui rencontrera demain
matin au ministère de l'éducation
nationale françois bayroux est composé
de 22 délégués un tiers de parisiens et
deux tiers de provinciaux mais hier soir
une certaine confusion a régné lors de
la désignation de ses délégués et ce
soir l'unef indépendante et démocratique
syndicats qui majoritaire dans les
universités appelle je cite les
étudiants à rester vigilants face à
toute tentative de récupération
politique
je vous disais il ya un instant c'est la
semaine prochaine s'annonce
particulièrement houleuse sur le plan
social avec un programme de défilés de
manifestations a sorti d'appel à la
grève dans les banques chez renault ou
encore dans l'enseignement
le tout sur fond de divisions syndicales
alors que la cgt ouvre demain son 42e
congrès et qu'à force ouvrière le
secrétaire général marc blondel a appelé
cet après midi je cite à une
généralisation de l'action pour le
retrait du plan juppé commentaire
yannick letranchant marc blondel très
convoité il faut dire qu'il a décidé de
lancer aujourd'hui un appel en appel
solennel à la généralisation du
mouvement à partir de lundi
c'est une radicalisation je vais
maintenant
demandez pratiquement à tous les
secteurs d'activité progressivement de
rentrer dans la grève c'est à dire de
l'alourdir à partir d'une position ça le
retrait du plan juppé
marc blondel entend bien s'installer
dans la tendance dure du mouvement
tendance qu'il partage avec louis
viannet de la cgt un mariage de raison
contre le plan de réforme de la sécurité
sociale le plan juppé cgt force ouvrière
même combat pour une même cause la grève
généralisée à tous les secteurs des
transports aux hôpitaux en passant par
les impôts etc
ça ressemble à un front syndical mais
l'union sacrée présente quelques failles
nicole notât de la cfdt et à l'un d'eux
le de la cftc s'affiche plus modérée
leur credo discuter pour réformer c'est
une histoire vieille de cent ans comme
le syndicalisme les durs face aux
modérés larbitre c'est la base
rarement modéré souvent très dures
toutes tendances confondues la france
s'installe dans les grèves des grèves
qui s'étendent se durcissent et se
politise nous allons y revenir à l'issue
d'une réunion à matignon et tous les
ministres concernés a été décidé la mise
en place de moyens de transport de
substitution en ile de france environ 15
sont car privés vont être mises en place
progressivement et les bateaux mouches
seront gratuits en fin d'après midi
reportage laurent bailly fredrik fort
cet après midi les responsables de la
sncf de la ratp et surtout les
représentants des compagnies d'autocars
privés ont donc rencontré bernard pons
et anne marie idrac les responsables
gouvernementaux des transports objectif
pallier la paralysie totale demain
encore des transports en commun en ile
de france
nous avons donc décidé avec le syndicat
des transports en région ile de france
de mettre en place un système de
dépannage un système d'assistance qui
bien entendu sur un modeste par rapport
à l'ampleur du problème
modeste parce que les 1700 autocars
affrétés ne pourront véhicule et que
cent mille personnes au lieu des 800
milles qui voyagent habituellement aux
heures de pointe
il en coûtera 3 millions de francs par
jour à l'état mais ce sera gratuit pour
les usagers
concrètement à partir de mardi matin 140
lignes de substitution seront installés
au départ des grandes villes de la
banlieue parisienne de 5h30 à 6h30
l'écart convergeront vers 13 estimations
dans paris même trajet en sens inverse
entre 16 et 17 heures dès demain dans
paris encore des vedettes et divers
bateaux mouches circuleront toutes les
20 minutes environ sur la seine entre
bercy et la maison de la radio
ces navettes fluviales ne seront en
service comme les autocars qu'à partir
de demain après midi enfin selon nos
informations si la grève devait se
prolonger quelques temps encore la ratp
pourrait sur présentation de la carte
orange 2 décembre accorder la gratuité
du transport pour janvier 96 alors que
maints blondel pour fo a appellé à une
généralisation de l'action pour le
retrait du plan juppé
la cgt a ouvert son congrès aujourd'hui
à montreuil près de paris pour son
actuel secrétaire général louis viannet
qui sera réélu sans problème lors de ce
congrès ce que la cgt reproche au
gouvernement ce n'est pas de vouloir
réformer de vouloir le faire seulement
en faisant payer les petits
cela dit louis viannet reste prudent sur
la généralisation des grèves
au secteur privé sur place pour france 2
agnès molinier luc bachofen
des militants galvanisés louis viannet
le secrétaire général de la cgt devrait
sortir renforcée de ce 45e congrès de
son syndicat
il est porté par les événements sociaux
même si aujourd'hui les cheminots en
grève depuis neuf jours lui voler la
vedette
soutenir les grévistes bien sûr mais
surtout appelé à l'unité syndicale
louis viannet a choisi de ne pas
disputer à force ouvrière la conduite du
mouvement
oui mes chers camarades je salue ce
processus formidable de mise en
mouvement unitaire d'enracinement
démocratique à l'appui duquel le monde
du travail pose maintenant avec force
ses exigences sur la table de ce petit
doigt et de ce qui va devenir une table
de négociations un appel à la
mobilisation que les militants
attendaient d'autant qu'ils sont appelés
mardi à une nouvelle journée de
manifestations ce congrès de la cgt est
historique non seulement parce qu'il
fait les 100 ans de l'organisation mais
surtout parce que c'est la première fois
qu'on congrès syndical se déroule en
plein conflit social de mardi s'annonce
comme un nouveau pic de la grève comme
disent les spécialistes avec de très
nombreuses manifestations notamment à
paris ce qui ne va pas arranger la
circulation ce lundi a déjà vu une
extension tous azimuts des conflits
sociaux de ce mouvement aux mille pattes
mais sans tête pour reprendre
l'expression de mes confrères
d'infomatin le point et il avait écrit
dans les rues de bordeaux ce matin
beaucoup de voitures mais aucun doute
ils sont restés au garage les 1200
chauffeur ayant suivi le mot d'ordre de
grève lancé par force ouvrière
tant que le gouvernement juppé ne retire
pas son blanc on continuera et je pense
que le mouvement va se durcir
sérieusement
entre marseille et aix en provence péage
gratuit ce matin pour les automobilistes
pendant 1h30
il aurait offert par des manifestants
d'odf qui les informe des risques selon
eux de la privatisation en angleterre
ils ont privatisé le gaz de france se
traduit par 40% d'augmentation sur la
voiture pour les usagers et on veut
éviter ça dans le nord les cheminots ont
reconduit la grève et aucun train n'a
circulé dans la région aujourd'hui
située sur identique demain avec
toujours les mêmes exceptions quatre
allers-retours d'eurostar paris
bruxelles et 5 paris londres qui sont
prévues pour demain en alsace à
fessenheim les grévistes d'edf se
relaient depuis cinq jours devant la
centrale ce matin ils ont bloqué
l'entrée pendant deux heures
une action qui fait partie d'un
mouvement tournant les grévistes
prévoient dès demain de s'attaquer à
d'autres sites à paris des défilés
organisés entre la place de la
république et la gare saint lazare a
rassemblé environ 50 mille personnes
selon la préfecture de police et 160
mille selon la cgt en tête de ce cortège
les cheminots grévistes
reportage agnès molinier et laurent
bailly ils défilent pour la troisième
fois
ils sont en grève depuis 11 jours et
aujourd'hui les cheminots sont plus
déterminés que jamais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ils durcissent le ton et les slogans
mort certaine et puisque cette sphère
plan juppé qui lui va aller
[Musique]
cette fois le plan jp la mort des
cheminots en direct
il avait nié les agents
autant le plan juppé dans le coglais
l'appel à manifester lancé aujourd'hui
par la cgt force ouvrière a largement
été sur son but se faire entendre par le
gouvernement j'ai surtout le sentiment
qu'il ne prend pas la mesure de ce qui
est en train de grandir dans le pays
ça oui j'en ai la conviction tous les
moyens étaient bons pour montrer sa
détermination mais surtout pour demander
des négociations du gouvernement
aujourd'hui il s'en voit bien ce qu'un
gouvernement qui négocie pas avec les
organisations syndicales c'est qu'il
n'est pas bien dans sa tête
aujourd'hui dans les rues de paris la
manifestation deux nuls de france a
drainé autant de monde que le
rassemblement national de mardi dernier
le cortège s'est disloqué à la gare
saint lazare et ce n'est qu'après que
quelques incidents éclatent et néo cons
d'isoler s'en sont pris à des voitures
et au mobilier urbain
je vous rappelle que dans quelques
instants nous devrions entendre une
communication gouvernementale du chef du
gouvernement en direct de l'hôtel de
matignon
arlette chabot c'est la deuxième fois en
quelques semaines qu alain juppé
s'adresse ainsi directement à l'opinion
oui effectivement que dans les sujets
graves et importants comme il considère
ce soir effectivement à la jupe et
préfèrent s'adresser directement à
l'opinion et aux français il veut
convaincre sûrement les français ce soir
comme il a tenté de convaincre la
représentation nationale comme l'on dit
à propos des députés de la nécessité de
la réforme et compte sûrement eu aussi à
nouveau expliquer aux français les
détails de la réforme et préciser les
garanties qu'il a donné cet après midi
aux fonctionnaires notamment pour
essayer de débloquer le conflit et les
crimes rappelle que nicole notât y
toujours avec nous et qu'elle leur a
l'occasion de répondre ensuite aux
propositions du premier disque que nous
allons entendre dans quelques instants
en direct de l'hôtel de matignon japon
patriotes
j'ai souhaité ce soir vous parler
personnellement parce que je sais que la
vie quotidienne de beaucoup d'entre vous
est difficile et que depuis quelques
temps elle est plus difficile encore je
pense à ceux d'entre vous qui veulent
travailler qui doivent parfois se lever
à trop 4 heures du matin pour rejoindre
leur bureau ou leur atelier dans les
grandes villes
vous devez parfois faire des heures de
marche et avec le froid qui revient
c'est de plus en plus dur
puis je pense aussi aux grévistes
je sais que ça n'est pas une décision
facile que de décider la grève ou pour
les plus modestes cela implique des
sacrifices alors il n'est plus possible
de continuer comme cela
nous sommes dans une situation de
blocage et d'affrontements dont chacune
et chacun va finir par pâtir il faut en
sortir il faut en sortir d'urgence et
pour ma part je souhaite de tout coeur
que les choses s'apaisent
certains formule des exigences ils
disent le préalable à toute discussion
c'est que le gouvernement retire son
plan de réforme et de sauver
de la sécurité sociale eh bien je veux
vous parler les yeux dans les yeux je ne
retirerai pas le plan de réforme et de
sauvegarde de la sécurité sociale parce
que ce serait une erreur et je dirais
même une faute que de le faire cela
irait contre l'intérêt de chacune et de
chacun d'entre vous et contre l'intérêt
de la france
ces réformes
nous les avons longuement préparé et je
crois aujourd'hui qu'elles sont à la
fois urgente et juste nous allons les
faire dans la concertation et ne
donneront des résultats
elles seront utiles voilà au moins
quatre raisons pour lesquelles il ne
faut pas les retirer et je voudrais
essayer si vous voulez bien écouter ce
soir de vous en convaincre
elles sont d'abord urgente si nous les
retirions que se passera t il n'y a
aucune autre proposition qui soit fait
partie que ce soit ce serait donc le
statu quo l'immobilisme et ce serait
très dangereux je voudrais apprendre
quelques exemples d'abord l'assurance
maladie vous savez bien que chaque année
en dépensant prestations plus qu'on
encaisse en cotisations cela veut dire
qu'il ya un moment où l'assurance
maladie va être en cessation de paiement
on ne pourra plus vous rembourser et ça
je ne le veux pas bien entendu autre
exemple mais régimes spéciaux de
retraite dont on parle beaucoup ces
temps ci c'est à dire les retraites des
fonctionnaires des agents de la ratp ou
la sncf
là encore il ya un problème pas tout de
suite pas demain pas prêt de même et
dans 10 ou 15 ans et gouverner c'est
prévoir ce qui va se passer dans 10 ou
15 ans quel est le problème
comprenez facilement
comment ça marche ce sont les
travailleurs actifs qui payent des
cotisations afin de financer les
retraites de ceux qui sont déjà
pensionnés pour que se passe-t-il on
rentre dans la vie de travail de plus en
plus par on arrête de travailler de plus
en plus tôt il ya donc de moins en moins
de cotisants et puis dans le même temps
les retraités qui ont pris la retraite
de plus en plus jeunes vives est heureux
grâce soit rendue aussi elles vivent de
plus en plus longtemps
le rapport entre les cotisants et les
inactifs est donc déséquilibré et ça va
continuer voilà pourquoi il faut faire
quelque chose
autre exemple encore la sncf nous sommes
tous très fiers de cette grande
entreprise nationale nous connaissons
les tgv c'est une belle réalisation de
l'industrie française mais ce qu'on ne
nous a pas dit ce qu'on nous a caché
trop longtemps c'est que cette
entreprise ne se porte pas bien
elle a des dettes considérables je ne
donnerai pas les chiffres parce que ne
parlent pas l'imagination elle perd de
l'argent chaque année et ce qui est plus
grave peut-être c'est que elle
transporte proportionnellement de moins
en moins de passagers et de marchandises
parce que elle résiste mal à la
concurrence d'autres modes de transport
en particulier
la route est donc là encore si nous ne
faisons rien cette entreprise va aller
vers des difficultés extrêmement grave
il y a donc urgence à agir je voudrais
que vous en soyez convaincu ses réformes
urgentes ne sont aussi juste et nous
avons tout fait pour qu'elle le soit ne
croyez pas tous les mensonges qu'on vous
raconte depuis quinze jours on vous
expliquant que les efforts ne seront pas
équitablement réparti ce n'est pas la
première chose que nous voulons faire
pour l'assurance maladie
d'abord un régime universel ça veut dire
quoi actuellement les français ne sont
pas égaux devant l'assurance maladie ils
ne reçoivent pas tous les mêmes
prestations et bien nous voulons que ça
change
nous voulons la même couverture maladie
pour tous les français c'est une mesure
de justice
et puis nous voulons aussi que les
efforts soient équitablement répartis je
voulais dit là je voudrais rétablir une
fois encore quelques vérités il n'est
pas vrai que les plus petits vont
supporter le poids du redressement de
l'assurance maladie
deux exemples précis le remboursement de
la dette sociale
rien ne sera demandée aux 5,2 millions
de français les plus modestes et pour la
cotisation maladie supplémentaire là
aussi je l'expliquais déjà à la
télévision je dois leur dire parce que
ceci était un peu perdu de vue les
retraités qui ne sont pas imposables
il y en a plus de 6 millions c'est près
de 60% de tous les retraités ne
supporteront pas cette cotisation
supplémentaire et les chômeurs qui ont
des ressources inférieures au smic 2
million et demi d'entre eux plus de 80%
de tous les chômeurs de la supporteront
pas non plus vous le voyez les français
les plus modestes ne seront pas appelés
à participer au redressement financier
de la sécurité sociale justice aussi en
ce qui concerne la sncf on vous a
beaucoup parlé du contrat de plan bien
jours et vous dire ce que c'est que ce
contrat de plan il ne consistent en
aucune manière à remettre en cause le
caractère d'entreprise public de la sncf
est là restera un service public j'en
prends l'engagement il ne remet pas en
question non plus le statut des
cheminots qui doit être défendu et il
prévoit très larges efforts de la
collectivité pour redresser la situation
de la sncf
les contribuables nous tout c'est nous
tous nous allons apporter dès 1996 et
sans contrepartie
37 milliards d' aide financière à la
sncf pour lui permettre de payer ses
dettes et ça continuera ensuite il n'y a
pas de blocage des salaires à la sncf il
n'y a pas non plus une liste de
suppressions de lignes ceci n'est pas
vrai ça ne figure pas dans le contrat de
plan est ce que nous demandons demandant
que l'entreprise se modernise qian
motive davantage tous ses collaborateurs
et qu'elles fassent preuve d'un nouveau
dynamisme commercial c'est bien le moins
qu'on puisse demander
en entreprise publique voilà donc
pourquoi les réformes sont justes
nous allons aussi les faire dans la
concertation si on vous dit parfois que
le gouvernement va tout décider tout
seul ce n'est pas vrai prenons l'exemple
des ordonnances n'est pas la première
fois qu'on fait des ordonnances tous les
gouvernements n'ont fait qu'elles soient
de droite ou de gauche
je me suis engagé à ce que ces
ordonnances qui sont nécessaires pour
aller vite soit l'objet d'une
information auprès du parlement mais
aussi auprès des partenaires sociaux
gelé a annoncé cet après midi à
l'assemblée nationale
de même j'ai demandé demandé à monsieur
marc o vous le connaissez vous l'avez
souvent ces jours derniers vous avez
apprécié un fois son calme et son
ouverture d'esprit j'ai demandé que
monsieur ben reçoivent toutes les
confédérations syndicales pour organiser
cette concertation
j'ai prévu une table ronde sur l'avenir
de nos services publics auquel nous
sommes très attachés
et puis enfin il ya les régimes spéciaux
de retraite et là je veux être aussi
très clairs aucune décision n'est prise
a priori je vous ai dit pourquoi ces
régimes connaissait des difficultés et
bien il faut remettre tout ça à plat et
j'ai chargé une commission composée de
personnalités très respecté très
évidente de toute sensibilité de faire
un livre blanc un peu comme monsieur
rocard l'avait fait pour le régime
général il ya quelques années mais sur
un base de ce livre blanc le moment venu
nous prendrons les décisions en
concertation avec tout ce que cela
concerne enfin et c'est la quatrième
raison pour laquelle il faut faire ces
réformes je suis persuadé qu elles
seront utiles qu'elles réussiront elles
ne sont pas faites pour brimer pour
gêner elles sont faites pour aider pour
aider la sncf pour aider l'assurance
maladie pour aider les régimes spéciaux
de retraite à se redresser
je suis persuadé que la france en
elle-même tous les atouts pour réussir
je ne comprends pas cette espèce de
sinistrose de morosité qui est en train
de s'installer
est-ce que nous mesurons suffisamment
bien la chance que nous avons d'être
français je vous pose tout simplement la
question y at il un seul pays au monde
où vous préféreriez vivre plutôt qu'en
france je le dis cela tout
particulièrement à nos gènes
ce sont beaucoup exprimés depuis
quelques temps parfois dans la rue
parfois bruyamment
c'est de la rage et il faut essayer de
les comprendre
il y a les attentes des lycéens et des
étudiants il ya aussi parfois l'angoissé
des jeunes des quartiers en difficulté
nous les avons entendus nous les avons
compris et le ministre de l'éducation
nationale françois bayrou a annoncé
dimanche dernier des mesures d'urgence
qui rejoignent complètement ce qui avait
été envisagé donc aujourd'hui sur ce
plan là toutes les raisons sont réunies
toutes les conditions sont réunies pour
que l'université les universités
françaises se remettent au travail
j'ai bien conscience que derrière ces
mesures d'urgence il ya quelque chose de
plus grave de plus profond et ce
phénomène plus grave et plus profond
c'est quoi c'est tout simplement
l'angoissé de l'avenir
c'est cette question que nous lance les
jeunes à quoi va servir le diplôme qui
me sera donné par l'université est ce
qu'il débouchera sur un emploi sur un
travail là nous retrouvons ce qui est le
fléau est essentielle aujourd'hui
auxquels nous devons faire face et
contre lequel nous devons lutter qui est
le fléau du chômage
j'avais fait de la bataille pour
l'emploi la priorité des priorités de
mon gouvernement et je n'ai pas changé
d'avis depuis six mois nous avons marqué
quelques points
le chômage de longue durée a reculé et
le contrat initiative emploi qui avait
été un des grands engagements de jacques
chirac pendant sa campagne
présidentielle est une réussite il
concerne près de 150000 français
aujourd'hui
en revanche et je le dis en toute
franchise pour le chômage des jeunes
nous avons subi des revers il a
progressé depuis deux ou trois mois et
ce n'est pas acceptable
il faut donc que toute la nation se
mobilisent il faut faire des réformes au
lycée à l'université les réformes de
fond elle aussi trop longtemps différée
qui vont nous permettre d'attaquer ce
fléau et puis il faut aussi que tous les
employeurs se mobilisent et je m'adresse
là à toutes les entreprises petites
moyennes ou grandes
nous avons fait beaucoup d'efforts
envers elle
depuis quelques mois nous avons allégé
leurs charges et pris toute une série de
décisions qui corresponde à ce qu'elle
attendait pour trouver un nouveau
dynamisme et bien il faut que à leur
tour maintenant elles tendent la main
qu'elle leur offre une chance d'entrer
pour une fois dans la vie de travail
qu'elle leur remette un peu le pied à
l'étrier c'est ce que j'ai appelé le
devoir national d'insertion il faut
maintenant le concrétiser ce sera la
nouvelle frontière que nous allons
ouvrir dans les mois qui viennent la
mobilisation pour l'insertion des jeunes
qu'ils soient étudiants ou pas étudiants
des quartiers en difficulté ou ou des
autres quartiers leur insertion dans la
vie professionnelle
voilà mes chers compatriotes ce que je
voulais vous dire ce soir la france a
besoin de réformes
nous allons les faire nous allons les
faire dans la concertation
nous allons les faire pour réussir et
nous réussirons aussi nous retrouvons
entre nous françaises et français
ce lien cette fraternité qui font notre
force
il ne faut pas dresser les français les
uns contre les autres les usagers contre
les grévistes les cheminots contre les
salariés du secteur privé
tout ceci ce sont de vieux combat ou de
vieux débats il faut se réunir se
rassembler se mobiliser pour réussir
nous allons réussir
je le crois de tout mon coeur et de
toutes mes forces
auparavant laurent fabius avait défendu
au nom du ps la motion de censure
déposée par son groupe en exhortant le
premier ministre à négocier sérieusement
avec roland sicard le point sur ce débat
parlementaire que vous avez pu suivre en
direct sur france 2 cet après midi
la journée politique d'alain juppé avait
commencé de boeuf réunion de l'ensemble
des députés de la majorité
quelques heures avant une motion de
censure il n'est jamais mauvais de
resserrer les boulons
les connaisseurs après ce changement de
décor l'après midi dans l'hémicycle
c'est là que l'opposition attend dès le
premier ministre opposition d'abord
socialistes avec laurent fabius au
créneau le débat en réalité sur le
contenu des réformes sur leur justice et
sur leurs méthodes
nous voulons des réformes mais nous ne
pensons pas qu on réforme à deux ou à
quatre sur un coin de table où on a fait
venir le technocrate de service un parti
socialiste au créneau un premier
ministre qui réagit plutôt et je veux
m'aurait pris monsieur fabius en
flagrant délit de mensonge mais
aujourd'hui on tousse c'est toute la
gauche qui étaient rassemblés
juppé doit renoncer à son plan le
gouvernement
des nus la même politique dont les
français aujourd'hui ont vraiment ras le
bol
l'opposition rassemblée mais la majorité
aussi eu des effets rpr cette fois serre
les coudes derrière le gouvernement tire
était critiqué c'est le fait qu'il y
avait peut-être
assez de négociations et pas assez de
discussions avant la présentation du
plan
je crois que les françaises et les
français comprennent la nécessité pour
leur propre protection se fermer pour
leur retraite
sur le plan parlementaire alain juppé
n'a rien être seuls les députés de
l'opposition votre la censure et
l'opposition ici c'est 85 députés sur
565 en fonction avec une majorité soudée
à l'assemblée le gouvernement peut être
tranquille deuxième invité politique à
l'autre bout de l'échiquier monsieur
robert hue monsieur v u bonsoir bien
alors je suppose que vous ne pensez pas
comme monsieur giscard d'estaing est ce
que vous pensez vous de votre côté qu'on
est vraiment passé là aujourd'hui
peut-être une crise sociale a une vraie
d'un véritable crise politique
vous savez ce que des millions et
millions de français disent actuellement
expriment actuellement ils disent une
chose simple
ils disent il faut retirer le plan juppé
et il faut négocier c'est très simple il
y a une grande question sociale qu'est
posée les français volent la négociation
il faut bien reconnaître qu'actuellement
monsieur juppé s'obstine à être sourd et
je voudrais dire que évidemment il y a
des problèmes de société qui sont posées
vous savez dans ce mouvement les gens se
parlent ils parlent de l'avenir de leurs
enfants il parle de l'avenir du pays sur
toutes ces questions évidemment il y à
des réflexions qui sont portés mais je
répète il faut absolument que monsieur
juppé entendre ce qui se passe
actuellement
vous dites il faut retirer le plan juppé
mais vous n'êtes pas contre toute
réforme de la sécurité sociale mais
certainement pas il faut absolument
réformer la sécurité sociale d'ailleurs
nous avons des propositions concrètes
pour réformer la la sécurité sociale
nous nous disons que je vais les résumés
nous pensons qu'il faut taxer les
revenus financiers au niveau
actuellement des de la taxation de
l'année cotisations des salaires ça
rapporterait actuellement 167 milliards
c'est la première mesure
la deuxième mesure c'est que nous
pensons qu'il faut voyez-vous moduler
les cotisations patronales en fonction
de de l'effort qui est fait en matière
d'emploi de croissance par l'entreprise
voilà des propositions constructives
j'ajoute à cela qu'il faut naturellement
relancer la croissance et il faut la
relance et par l'emploi il faut la
relance et par les salaires d'ailleurs
une des propositions fortes que j'ai
fait dans la campagne présidentielle me
semble complètement d'actualité
ils font relancer l'allée des salaires
je pense qu'une augmentation de 2000
francs minimum des salaires tous les
salaires de moins de 15000 francs
relancerait les choses dans ce pays
monsieur il joue mais là que vous pensez
que l'on doit continuer à faire la grève
et négocier pendant la grève comme le
disait hier soir ici même monsieur
blondel ou est-ce que vous pensez que
d'une certaine façon on peut faire
confiance au gouvernement désormais
arrêter la grève et discuter mais ils
font que le mouvement se poursuivre
puisque actuellement monsieur juppé
reste sourd monsieur juppé dit les les
français ne comprennent pas mes
propositions
c'est lui qui ne comprend pas les
français voilà la réalité il faut
aujourd'hui c'est simple il ne s'agit
pas d'attendre plusieurs jours il doit
négocier il faut qu'il retire son plan
et qu'ils négocient je crois que c'est
extrêmement simple c'est ce que disent
les françaises et les français vous
savez les françaises et les français en
ont assez que depuis quinze ans qu'on
leur rabâche toujours la même chose
qu'on les traite de laon pour les traite
avec arrogance qui lie à haut niveau de
l'état
une des ddd docteur je sais tout qui
décide de tout ils font tout et qui ne
tiennent pas compte de ce que disent les
français
et ça c'est insupportable ces mêmes gens
sortent des mêmes écoles
ils sont dans les mêmes conseils
d'administration tout ça ça ne va pas
c'est ce que disent aujourd'hui les
français il faut écouter la france reste
que dans les dépôts sncf ratp les
assemblées ont été assez vives
aujourd'hui souvent et pour la première
fois cet après midi des autobus et
surtout des métros se sont remis à
circuler à paris frédéric paul crotta
joseph baltique
c'était en fin d'après midi un train
toutes les 20 minutes sur la ligne
numéro un la joie éclate mais elle ne
concerne qu'une extrême minorité
d'usagers de ligne seulement proposent
des rames
mille familles cement de reprise nous
constatons que des trains pourraient
circuler et que les piquets de grève s'y
opposent difficile de confirmer cette
information ni la direction de la ratp
ni les grévistes ne nous ont autorisés à
visiter plusieurs stations la direction
avait affirmé également que des
grévistes s'étaient couchés sur les
rails mais là encore impossible de
vérifier ces grévistes qui sortent d'une
assemblée générale ne souhaite pas
s'exprimer
oui
quelques privilégiés ont donc retrouvé
tout à l'heure leur métro mais sans trop
y croire
ces déserts j'avais pris le métro à six
heures 6h10 6h et 6h30 certains car avec
aussi peu de monde les gens sont plus
habituel prendre de l'impression des ils
ont raison parce qu'il n'y a pas
beaucoup qui passe il y en a d'autres où
ça lui on sait pas comment savoir les
mollets qui démontre les pneus le
parisien est décidément devenu méfiant
même dans le métro il conserve sa petite
reine ouais je sais enfin maintenant je
vais le donner aux gars daratt écrit
le mouvement social se cherche et fo et
la cgt demande au gouvernement d'avancer
le sommet social prévu le 21 décembre
calendrier de la discussion
laurent bailly agnès molinier samedi
c'est la date des syndicats
celle des manifestations que force
ouvrière prépare avec la cgt et les
enseignants de la fsu
en revanche une autre date leur pose
problème celle choisie par alain juppé
pour organiser le sommet social chacun
de son côté marc blondel et louisiane et
ont écrit au 1er mai et j'espère que
cette fois il me répondra ou plus
exactement je me fous de la formule de
politesse même s'il y en a pas mais la
bonne réponse ça serait par exemple qui
disent le 21 c'est trop tard on avance
et 21 décembre c'est trop loin parce que
si l'on veut véritablement créer les
conditions pour une détente
il faut pas donner l'impression que
envoie la balle de semaine en semaine
en attendant dès aujourd'hui des
réunions préparatoires ont lieu les
enseignants de la fsu ont été reçus cet
après midi par alain juppé notre vrai
souci nous c'est que ce sommet social
véritablement permettre d'avancer sur
toutes les questions de l'emploi peu
nous importe je dirais la date s'il est
véritablement bien préparé il s'il peut
aboutir ce soir bernard pons le ministre
des transports rencontre les fédérations
de cheminots
mercredi prochain le ministre dominique
perben rencontrera les fonctionnels le
président de la sncf jean bergougnoux a
offert sa démission ministre des
transports qu'il acceptait ce soir son
successeur devrait être désigné en
conseil des ministres mercredi prochain
le patron de la sncf était en sursis
depuis cinq jours après avoir été
publiquement désavoué à la télévision
par alain juppé qui avait dénoncé donc à
la télévision les carences du dialogue
social à l'intérieur même de
l'entreprise sncf
[Musique]